[Music]
with so many awesome TV series to watch
on Netflix it can be hard to pick just
one and stick with it when it comes to
stranger things though the only hard
thing about it will be unglue in your
eyes from the screen this wicked show
seems to have a genre of its own which
circles around horror and science
fiction watch until the end to find out
why stranger things is facing a lawsuit
new here don't forget to give us a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
and if you love stranger things as much
as we do stick around while we jump into
the core reasons its third season got
pushed back the duffer brothers want to
perfect their crap if there's one thing
that can bore an audience it's a tired
plotline with this in mind the duffer
brothers are definitely starting to feel
some pressure sure their show stranger
things had a successful first two
seasons but that doesn't pave the way
for future success all in all the duffer
brothers know that the stakes are high
and if pushing back their release date
is all it takes to get things right
that's cool with them there's nothing
worse than falling in love with an epic
show only to watch it deteriorate before
your eyes so despite the fact that
stranger things season 3 has been
postponed
we are certain we'll be rewarded with
the best season yet
it's a handcrafted show filming a
production takes a lot of time a lot of
work and a lot of money
while the duffer brothers have more than
enough to go around people need to sleep
eat and repeat although many stranger
things fans that its newest season would
drop in time for Halloween this just
isn't the case a good thing to keep in
mind is that stranger things has always
released their seasons sporadically so
just because he's in two dropped in the
fall of 2017 doesn't mean that the scene
will happen in 2018 and so on
realistically the duffer brothers
believe that season 3 will be completed
by the summer of 2019 so why is there
such of
big gap between the second and third
season it's quite simple really
the show is handcrafted simply filming
real-life events can take a lot of time
so imagine how long creating props sets
and costumes for an IDI sci-fi series
can take top it off with special effects
and it's all starting to make sense
after all there's no such thing as
cutting corners when the goal is
perfection
Winona Ryder's got a lot on her plate
perhaps one of the show's biggest
selling points was the inclusion of
renowned actress Winona Ryder this two
time oscar-winning actress means
business which prompted many of her fans
to tune into the new Netflix series
while she's devoted most of her time to
filming stranger things
the actress does have an acting career
to keep up with writers been filming for
the upcoming movie destination wedding
which is set to be released in late
August of 2018 she and her co-star Keanu
Reeves have been devoting their time to
this production which can make it
difficult for her to abide to the duffer
Brothers schedule now that the filming
for destination wedding has been
completed nothing standing enjoys buyers
away the younger crowd Winona Ryder
isn't the only one who's bitten off more
than she can chew it's quite obvious
that stranger things is jam-packed with
an extremely talented crew however most
of its main characters are young adults
teenagers and children knowing this it's
unreasonable for the duffer brothers to
put their production before the
well-being and education of their actors
on top of all this many of these young
actors are also in the middle of filming
other movies and TV series take Finn
wolfhard who plays the role of Mike
wheeler as an example at only 15 years
old he's already in the process of
filming for movies and two TV series
which can easily prolong the stranger
things filming schedule all in all the
Duggar brothers don't seem to mind this
one bit after all it gives them enough
time to perfect their script and any
issues that come their way
and wolfhard isn't the only one who has
his hand stuck in the cookie jar this is
made obvious by the fact that nearly
every young stranger things star is
working on a handful of projects at the
same time actors like Milly Bobby Brown
Natalya Dyer Joe Keary and Noah snob
have their hands full for the time being
and we're more than happy for them
nevertheless we want the third season of
stranger things and we want it now legal
issues
Charlie Kessler a writer and movie
director has now filed a lawsuit against
the duffer brothers and the reason
behind it is pretty surprising Kessler
claims that he approached them with an
idea for a TV series back in 2012 this
idea holds a lot of similarities between
his short film Montauk and the much
anticipated stranger things itself
Kessler is convinced that the Dever
brothers stole his ideas and are trying
everything to cover up their tracks
Kessler short film Montauk won an award
of the Hamptons International Film
Festival which sort of contradicts his
claim if millions of people have already
seen this short film why hasn't anyone
pointed out how similar it is stranger
things regardless Kessler says that he
pitched his ideas to the duffer Brothers
and got shot down only to later see his
work come to life without any
recognition to further his gates Kessler
is trying to prove that the casting call
for the role of Barbara had hints of the
title Montauk attached to it instead of
the title stranger things if this is
true the duffer brothers might just have
a big lawsuit on their hands with this
going on things like filming and writing
season 3 of stranger things might just
get pushed back let's just hope that the
duffer brothers didn't do anything Shady
to warrant their success are you shocked
to find out about Kessler's lawsuit if
so check out his short film for yourself
and let us know if the similarities in
fact exist
should there be enough evidence
I just have a huge paycheck coming his
way in the meantime tell us which
stranger things character you're most
excited see come season three and that's
a wrap for the real reasons why stranger
things 3 got delayed don't forget to
subscribe if you want more amazing
content to come your way thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]